the family of a 15-year-old boy run over
and killed last week is speaking out
tonight they say anthony de la torre
died while his aunt who was reportedly
under the influence was behind the wheel
sasha loftis joining us live in studio
with more on their message to our
community it is a story you will only
see on eight news now ryan those who
loved anthony de la torre are dealing
with unimaginable pain right now but
they're sharing his story to call for
justice in his death and raise awareness
to stop this from happening to anyone
else
he just wanted to make everyone happy a
life stolen far too soon those who loved
anthony de la torre remember who he was
it's really difficult to come to terms
with my nephew not ever being here again
the 15-year-old died thursday nearly a
week after he was run over by a car
19-year-old destiny jimenez who the
family has identified as anthony's
paternal aunt is facing charges
arrest reports say she admitted to being
under the influence of marijuana and
alcohol when she reportedly got behind
the wheel of an suv and allowed de la
torre to skateboard while holding on to
the side it's hard to wrap my head
around that i won't ever see him again
because of a mistake that somebody made
now as those who loved anthony the most
mourn for what his life could have been
they want to remind others to stay sober
i understand we're in las vegas and
i see stories all the time about you
know people drinking and driving and
running somebody over or hitting
somebody while they also demand justice
in his death and hold on to the memories
he gave them i love him to the moon and
past the stars
jimenez was charged with felony dui
resulting in bodily harm and driving
without a license now that charge could
change now that anthony has died police
also say another woman was originally
driving and allowed jimenez to switch
with her so anthony could ride along on
his skateboard that woman is not facing
any charges